what were you like in school i was a
[ __ ] nightmare
were you oh my god i was terrible i was
like really smart kid but i just didn't
give a [ __ ]
yeah school seemed a little ridiculous
to me i like being friends with like the
sick lady
dude i would get a boner and go into the
office and tell him i had i was sick and
i'm just pointing my
boner in my old room 15 16.
you know and i'd be like what did you do
she would give me ice
she would put ice in your pee should she
ice it or not no she would give me two
bags give me a little pack
and then a little pack i mean two bags
it was a [ __ ] hell she gave you half
a cube
yeah she cut it in half and it's like
that's [ __ ] weird i got expelled from
school four times
four times i got expelled this is true
story what happened to you man you seem
like
oh no i was [ __ ] people are like think
that but i was [ __ ] reckless dude
yeah
my friends were all they i had some
hardcore friends and uh
dude trent rezner what the [ __ ] did you
do
yeah i was [ __ ] trending who was your
friends man
dude we were stealing cars and [ __ ]
we're like 14 friends and gangs and
shits oh
but i got expelled for pulling fire
alarms we could go smoke a cigarette
yeah but it was like a 3 000 compound
school
so we'd empty out the whole [ __ ]
school just so we could rip butts and
we'd go back in
yeah i got pinched twice then i smoked a
blunt
in school so i went to the auditorium me
and my buddies
slide up a fat blunt and this is the era
when like cypress hill came out
yeah the real game on dude
so we light up a blunt cops kick in the
door we get handcuffed we get like
filed out in front of everybody too so
it's dope it like serious [ __ ] crap
yeah people like what they do i was just
like that's what you said no i started
crying
but i got court-ordered rehab after that
really and then i got
i got [ __ ] um i put a sign on a
substitute teacher's butt
then i got thrown out for that too [ __ ]
sounds hardcore
we were [ __ ] rogue dude yeah we stole
a car
what kind of car was it we it was cold
out so we were just
we had a screwdriver and we would
[ __ ] jimmy cars
yeah and uh we stole it and now
everybody goes look at the glove
compartment see if there's anything
open the glove compartment and there was
a [ __ ] rosary and a bible
and an id card it was a priest's car
and i was like get me the [ __ ] out of
this car my buddy's like dude chill
i go get me the [ __ ] out of here so i
mean diarrhea
so me and my other me and my other buddy
josh
that sounds like a real winner josh was
caught and i was cool he was
yeah he was catholic though so he
freaked out and i was really really
religious
but i was religious enough i was like
get me out of the stolen priest car we
get out my buddies take it
go joyriding they get [ __ ] pulled
over
all [ __ ] juvied up they went [ __ ]
down
really yeah they got clipped i i never
got i always like knew what i was doing
yeah you know what i mean like i had the
wherewithal my buddy said that the other
day i
did a show minnesota and he came to the
show and uh
he told me he was like dude you always
like had another
sense of like this is going bad yeah
yeah yeah one time some cops told us to
follow him to the police station we were
under arrest right
my buddy's driving and then other
buddies in the passenger seat i'm in the
back seat
at a stoplight i'm like hey guys i'm i'm
out
i'm just going to jet and like what the
[ __ ] dude
we're like following the cop right
they're like what the [ __ ] dude we're
going to
we're going to get arrested i was like
yeah i'm not you know i'm
i'm gonna just walk home i was like my
home's only like i'm niall
it's like i'm just gonna kind of slip
out casually when you guys leave this
stop light and that's what i did
and they [ __ ] went and got arrested
yeah i guess uh sometimes it was just
this wherewithal like oh this is not
going to go well right here i'm out
yeah i did this this is my claim of like
serious
get out senses i've told this story
before on some [ __ ] but uh
i'll just tell it real quick so me and
my buddies had a posse and we lived in
this neighborhood in saint paul
and there was a abandoned house across
the alley from my buddy's place
so we went to this house and had a party
we're like 14. abandoned or for lease
it was abandoned okay it was like
somebody bought it but it was like this
big old house yeah
right off the train tracks oh yeah
so we go and have a party we're sitting
at chicks we got booze we got smokes
so one of my buddies he was just rogue
his parents like weren't around one of
those yeah you know
both ups drivers yeah yeah they're both
[ __ ]
packages oh yeah so he we're in the
middle of party we're all buzzed he
takes a [ __ ] molotov cocktail we were
defacing spray painting everything
this guy goes star wars rogue one
takes it throws it fire we all dip out
we run
our crew go across the alley to my
friend's house
and we're like holy [ __ ] can we crash in
the house
we [ __ ] the next day wake up it's on
the news there's cops
all over the neighborhood everywhere
somebody calls us like from another
house they're like
dude there's cops all over the place
we're looking out the windows there's
like 30 cops surrounding it but like we
find out that there's they're everywhere
so my buddy's like let's just chill here
and i go no we gotta get the [ __ ] out of
here they're gonna find us because we
they know that we're like the
neighborhood ruffians yeah yeah
so i'm like we gotta get out of here
they're like no stay here and i go no so
i go
to him we're all starter jackets and
chains and [ __ ] yeah
so i go [ __ ] this i go do you have a
collared shirt and he goes yeah
i put on his dad's like shorts i cinch
them
put on a collared shirt i go does your
dad have a tennis racket and he goes
yeah
take the tennis racket fix my hair
walk out the back with my tennis racket
walk down the alley there's like
five cops at the end of the alley
watching me and i go hey what's up
officer
and they're like glaring at me and
they're like hey what's going on city
bus pulls up i jump on it
try go back to my house i'm like holy
[ __ ]
i found out after the fact cops busted
in and
clipped all my friends 15 minutes later
or 20 minutes whatever it was a little
bit later they [ __ ] had narrowed it
down that it was our house they didn't
see me coming out of the house so i
wasn't like that
but i just walking down the alley with
my tennis racket and they all got
[ __ ]
nailed i love how you look so normal
these local cops like yeah they were
like who's this guy played tennis
he had a tennis court in that he was
playing tennis on the train tracks
just hitting against a moving train like
[ __ ] navratilova
just [ __ ]
getting after it dude they're like this
dude's [ __ ] gonna go to wimbledon
it's a month he can play tennis anywhere
but yeah dude i've survived some [ __ ]
yeah it seemed like you've been through
a lot man
too much that's why i settled on
diarrhea and farting
even today good evening good afternoon
and other times
thanks for watching that video you just
saw i mean it was okay
but the next video you can watch could
be way better what if you watch a video
right now that changes
your life well you could watch this one
or watch this one
watch this one watch this one watches
one
ah